a good evening welcome to the Americans
in natural history my name is Rob de sel
and a curator here at the Museum and the
co-director of the molecular
laboratories that most of you didn't
know we had molecular biology
laboratories here but we do and that's
what I think makes tonight's
presentation as so exciting it's the
first in a series of a lot of things
that will be happening here at the
Museum over the next year or two with
respect to genomics in and Human Genome
Project in April and May of this year in
spring will have a seminar series on the
impact of genomics on medicine later on
in the fall we'll have a two-day
symposium here at the Museum inviting in
all of the luminaries of the genomics
field to discuss genomics and the ethics
social issues legal issues etc and then
next year in 2001 the museum is planning
a full-scale exhibition on genomics and
genetics and so we're quite excited by
all of this activity around genomics and
I think it's quite fitting that dr.
Ridley kicks off some of the the events
that we're planning for the next year
year and a half with his talk tonight
dr. Ridley without further ado then I
want to introduce dr. Ridley he received
his PhD in zoology from Oxford
University he worked for the economist
for several years and four three of
those years he was the Washington bureau
chief he's an accomplished lecturer and
author is the author of a wonderful book
called the Red Queen it's a it's a book
one of my favorites he's also the author
of a book called the origins of virtue
and tonight he's going to speak to us
about his new release from Harper
Collins publishers genome the
autobiography of a species in twenty
three chapters dr. Ridley
thank you rob very much indeed for that
kind introduction and and I must say
what a great honor it is to be here to
speak at the American Museum of Natural
History it's a dream come true it's a
wonderful place my book is a
whistle-stop tour through the human
genomes through all the genes that make
ups as a species and what I've done in
the book is I've stopped at every
chromosome there are 23 of them and
tried to tell a story about how we are
who we are and why we are and how the
new understanding of genetics is
shedding light on that because I
genuinely believe we're on the brink of
an explosion of new knowledge about
ourselves as a result of the human
genome project which is coming to
fruition even as we speak just a few
short months ago about twenty percent of
the human genome had been deciphered
it's now up beyond forty percent and by
June it will be complete at least in a
first draft and I think that's a very
important moment I think it's it's quite
interesting that it's happening just as
a millennium ends and another one begins
i think it's it's it's that important if
you like as an issue I sometimes try to
argue that is the discovery of DNA and
of genes is the most important thing in
the second was the most important thing
in the second millennium now finished
well maybe not depending on whether you
decide that this is the last year of the
second millennium of the first year of
the third and there are other candidates
of course for the most important
discoveries you know relativity gravity
etc very important things I realize
double entry bookkeeping has been
suggested to me is more important but
maybe maybe not the phone on stick
frying pan has its adherence as you can
probably tell I'm a bit of an optimist
about genes genetics and genomics and in
some ways I'm a little dismayed that
we're not all as optimistic as me
because I do think that there's a lot of
pessimism about about the application of
genetics a lot of concern and a lot of
anxiety but then when I think about it I
think perhaps it's better that way
perhaps we do tread into this genetic
few
with a little caution perhaps that way
we'll be careful that we don't put a
foot wrong now it's a century ago this
year that the concept of the gene really
entered science in 1900 the discoveries
of Gregor Mendel which had been made 40
years before but had been forgotten
about were rediscovered and genetic the
word gene was kind and all the whole
subject of genetics began and I think
it's worth reflecting on what for the
first half of the 20th century people
knew about genes because it's actually
quite an interesting little nugget of
information that Mendel discovered and
that that is sort of obvious when you
think about it been in a way it's a very
counter intuitive idea I have brown eyes
you probably can't see from there but
it's true and my daughter has blue eyes
and my father has blue eyes and what
that tells you is that I carry the gene
for blue eyed for blue eyes but that
during the whole of my life I've carried
that gene but it's never been
contaminated by my own brown eyes if you
like somehow the blue eyed nature of the
gene is has survived inside me despite
the fact that the obvious expression of
eye color in me is a different one and
so that tells you that genes are
particles they're not fluids they don't
blend we are not a mixture of our
parents essences we are a sort of
mixture of little particles of
inheritance which are quite distinct
from each other what what possible how
could that property be explained and for
the first half of the century the
question what is a gene was was was
reverberating through biology and there
were lots of ideas there were a lot of
very far-fetched ideas about what how
these properties could be explained how
something could be so specific as to
tell me what color my eyes would be and
yet somehow remain intact within me and
not be contaminated by the color of my
own eyes and the answer of course turned
out to be completely different from the
one that everybody was thinking it
wasn't anything to do with quantum
mechanics or chemistry or energy states
of
it turned out to be a simple question of
digital coded information genes turned
out to be little messages messages
written in a language very like the one
we use written that is in a linear
digital form with symbols set out in a
string that's essentially what Jim
Watson and Francis Crick discovered in
1953 when they discovered the double
helix and the structure of DNA they
discovered that DNA was just a way of
carrying a digital coded message and now
in the 50 years since then we've moved
from realizing that there is such a
thing there is a recipe an instruction
manual if you like inside us to being
able to read the entire book because it
is a book it is not even a metaphor to
say that it's a book and it's a very
very very big book there are three
billion letters in the human genome some
animals salamanders have much bigger
genomes so as it's nothing to be proud
of that our book is three billion
letters long it's about a billion words
in other words because it's little
written in three letter words and that's
eight hundred times as long as the Bible
or five thousand times as long as my
book which is therefore cheap at the
price it's a very very big book but it's
also a very small book they're each of
you sitting here today has 100 trillion
copies of it inside you that's 100
million million copies of it inside you
so imagine having 100 million million
copies of 800 Bibles inside you and that
gives you some idea of the the both the
compression of this thing and also the
size of it the size of the task reading
it from beginning to end now knowing
when we come to have a first draft of
this document and it will literally fit
on one CD it's not that big so you can
still get it on a CD in a in a year or
so you'll be able to buy it it'll be
called the reference genome that's it's
an average of two hundred people and the
interesting bit of course will be how
each of you varies from that reference
genome if you like you know it's not
necessarily going to be the same in all
of us there are lobbying
crucial differences once we've got it
what does it you know what does it tell
us of course in a sense it's it's going
to be gobbledygook to us for a long time
there's lots of bits of it we're not
going to understand but the first thing
is going to tell us how many genes we've
got at the moment we think human beings
have about 80,000 genes but it could be
anything from 60,000 to 140,000 nobody
actually knows that is particular
messages in that inside that message
which are translated and used but the
the the the importance of this document
for me falls into three different
categories the applications the
implications and the mystery and if I
could just illustrate those three
different categories with one particular
stretch of text on the tip of each
chromosome each of the 23 chromosomes on
either end of it there is a little word
is the word is TT AGG in the four-letter
alphabet of of DNA and it's repeated
maybe a thousand times end to end and
it's known as the telomere and the
telomere is like the is thought to be
like the the little plastic bit on the
end of a shoelace that prevents it
frying as a technical term for the
little plastic bit on the end of a
shoelace but I can't remember what it is
maybe someone can enlighten me and
because what happens is when the
chromosome gets copied that stretch of
repeats of that phrase gets shorter and
shorter and shorter there's a bit left
off every time and but because it's
repeated over and over again it never
quite gets so short in your life that
the actual chromosome itself begins to
fray well it turns out that the telomere
is has a crucial medical application
because when you get cancer one of the
things that that happens is that the
telomere event if the if the cell keeps
dividing the tip of the chromosome
eventually starts to fray because it
runs out of repeats of this telomere
phrase and cancer only turns malignant
therefore if it has a special enzyme
switched on inside the cell called
telomerase which repairs the telomere so
by attacking team
gamma rays which is not needed in the
rest of the body otherwise you can
actually find a new way of attacking
cancer so there's and that's one of the
most promising current new ideas for for
treating cancer so there's a medical
application from the knowledge but it
also has if you like an ethical
implication because if we understand
that aging is based on the fraying of
chromosomes the shortening of telomeres
and indeed we know that people who live
particularly long lives quite often seem
to have longer telomeres than other
people then we begin it's one of the key
ingredients of understanding why the
body ages and how the body ages and if
you can switch telomerase on in other
people in people's bodies and repair
their chromosomes then you may be able
to make them live for longer now if we
could all live for twice as long if we
could live for 140 years and scientists
have already bread fruit flies that live
twice their normal lifespan so there's
no reason they shouldn't breed human
beings to do that if they put their
minds to it then what would be the
implications for society would we all go
through several careers in our life
would pension funds go bankrupt you know
there are the implications are many folk
manifold and extraordinary but thirdly
telomeres tell us another little thing
because telomerase the the enzyme which
repairs telomeres has as part of its
working machinery a piece of chemical
called RNA which as many of you I'm sure
now is a sort of working copy of DNA and
it turns out that the more we look at
telomerase the more we begin to see that
it's actually a very very old piece of
machinery left over from what was known
we think as the RNA world which existed
before even the invention of DNA some
three and a half billion years ago so
that's an example of the mystery that we
can find in the genome no practical
application for that no ethical
implication but just sheer mystery of
knowledge and and the excitement of
discovering things another example of
the the mysteries that we can the
questions we didn't even know we could
pose before we understood genes
the fact that looking inside this book
this 800 Bible length book the first
thing that we've found out about it is
that ninety seven percent of it is known
as junk DNA it's it serves no apparent
purpose at all it's never translated
during our lifetime it's never used to
make proteins it's never it's not
doesn't consist of jeans the jeans are
about three percent and the junk DNA is
about ninety seven percent this seems a
very odd and wasteful way to go about
our lives and there are certainly
important functions buried in this
ninety-seven percent control functions
for jeans and so on but an awful lot of
it seems to be there for a really rather
strange reason it's there because it's
good at being there it's there because
it's good at a tent attracting the
attention of mechanisms in the cell for
copying itself by far the Communist
sequence in our genes is a little
hundred letter long phrase that's
repeated over and over again it's called
the aloe sequence and it constitutes
about 14 times the fourteen percent of
the entire genome that's about five
times as much as all the genes put
together and the aloe sequence is simply
one of these it's like it's like if you
like a computer virus or a chain letter
it's just it's parasitized the genome
it's literally got in there and copied
itself this doesn't happen in real books
of course it's just as well it would be
very terse and for authors if it did but
this is one of the examples of how the
genome is a very strange place and there
are mysteries we didn't even know we had
to solve which we're now coming across
inside there but of course the junk DNA
actually has a practical purpose because
it's in the junk DNA that you find the
repeats of phrases that enable you to do
genetic fingerprinting DNA
fingerprinting of the kind that was made
particularly famous by OJ Simpson and
Monica Lewinsky genes are what make us
different from each other blue eyes
versus brown eyes brown hair versus
black hair but they're also what make us
similar if you were sitting here
listening to me now and you turn to your
left and saw that there was a gorilla
sitting on one side of you in a human
being on the other
you would be struck immediately not by
looking at the gorilla and seeing how
different it was you'd be struck how
similar the human being was on the other
side of you and of course that
similarity is under lane by genes and if
instead of a gorilla it was an oak tree
you'd be even more struck at this by the
similarities by with a person or even
similarities with a gorilla the said
you'd both have five fingers on each
hand 32 teeth in your mouth and so on
because it's its genes its genes that we
have in common both with other people
and with other species that make us the
shape we are genes are not just about
differences they're also about
similarities and the second great
surprise that's come out of the book
that that were beginning to read is that
we are ninety-eight percent chimpanzees
were 97% gorillas and indeed chimpanzees
and ninety-seven percent gorillas so the
two most closely related apes in in the
entire egg family are the human being
and the chimpanzee they're not the human
being that they're not the chimpanzee
and the Carillo for example now we
wouldn't have known that if we couldn't
read genes it's by looking it's by
comparing genetic sequences that we find
that out you can't tell that from the
anatomy from the from the body of a
chimpanzee you might well conclude that
it was more closely related to a gorilla
and to us but it turns out know that we
are the two most closely related ape
species now people say it's ridiculous
i'm not ninety-eight percent chimpanzee
i'm completely different from a
chimpanzee and they have a point of
course they're completely different but
if you think about it in the big
evolutionary perspective if you start
with a single blob an amoeba four
billion years ago and you try and turn
it into a human being or into a
chimpanzee about ninety eight percent of
the things you'd have to do to it would
be the same in with in both cases as i
said you'd have to give it five fingers
on each hand 32 teeth in its mouth and
so on if you see it in that perspective
compared to an amoeba now we are about
ninety-eight percent chimpanzees and
that's in another thing about the genome
is that it's a sort of record of
everything that's happened to us
over the past four billion years that's
why I've called my book the
autobiography of a species in twenty
three chapters because in a way the
genome is our autobiography both as a
species and as the preceding species
from which we are evolved because if you
think being 98% a chimpanzee is bad for
your self-esteem it gets worse when you
consider that there are quite large
similarities between ourselves and fruit
flies my particular favorite set of
genes are group of genes called the hox
genes which were discovered in fruit
flies in the mid 80s they they lie in a
group on one of the fruit fly
chromosomes and nose to tail and they
determine the body shape of the animal
so that if one of them is missing there
is a part of the body missing in and it
as it develops or if one of if there are
two in one place then you get an extra
bit of the body in the middle and so on
and the first gene in the group
determines where the head should go in
in the embryo it determines the shape of
the head and the last gene determines
the shape of the other end of the animal
and so on in between so rather
extraordinarily these genes actually
seems to sort of map in the same they
actually lie in the same order as the
part of the body they as the bits of the
body they determine and when scientists
found these hox genes in fruit flies
they thought this was very exciting
because at last it was getting a real
handle on the mysterious process of
embryonic development and how a
shapeless egg gets turned into a very
beautifully shaped fly but then they
went looking in Mouse DNA to see whether
or not there were similar sequences to
these hox genes and they immediately
found exactly the same group of genes
that were very very strikingly similar
and seemed to be doing the same job once
again if one of them is missing you get
a missing part of the mouse's spine and
so on now we are 92% mice roughly so
it's no great surprise to find that
we've got these hox genes too and
they're so similar to fruit fly jeans
that you can actually
knock out a fruit fly gene in an
embryonic fruit fly replace it with a
human gene as long as it's that if it's
the third fruit fly gene you replace it
with a third human gene and the fruit
fly will then develop perfectly normally
you can do what it's known as genetic
rescue and it's using the gene from one
species to rescue the development of
another species and what this tells us
tells us two things first of all that we
all read each other software we're all
using the same operating system if you
like but it tells us more than that
because it tells us that the common
ancestor of human beings and fruit flies
must have used these jeans when it
existed and we know from the fossil
record as this museum displays that the
common ancestor of arthropods and
mammals lived more than 600 million
years ago so we're beginning to get a
glimpse of what this animal looked like
that was 600 million years old and what
kinds of things it did we know it had a
segmented body now it's known in the
literature as the roundish flatworm
which is a way of keeping your options
open because they don't know whether it
was roundish or flat but that's just an
example of how genes can take us way
back in time and tell us things about
events that took place hundreds of
millions of years ago now I've talked
about a couple of examples of the
mystery but of course for most of us the
importance of the genome is going to be
what it does to medicine and whether or
not it it improves our chances of
defeating various important diseases on
the whole genetics and genomics are
discussed almost entirely in medical
terms and that's partly why I've started
this talk by not talking about medical
applications I think there's perhaps too
much emphasis on how genes and diseases
are associated and we sometimes end up
with the impression that genes are there
to cause diseases which is of course
just as misleading as to say that hearts
called hearts are there to cause heart
attacks but sometimes it's the only
thing we know about a gene that when
it's not working you get a particular
disease
and a good example of this is a gene on
chromosome 4 which is associated with
Huntington's disease it was the first it
was one of the first disease genes to be
located and a very very brave woman
named Nancy Wexler who was herself at
fifty percent risk of this disease was
the person who was really responsible
for tracking it down in the mid-1980s as
many of you may know if you've read her
sister's book on the subject she went to
Venezuela to an area around Lake
Maracaibo where there are lots of people
in an extended kin network who have this
Huntington's disease and by taking blood
from people who had the disease and
comparing the genes in it with blood
from people who did not have the disease
but were from the same family she was
able to see whether she could find a
consistent difference between them and
thereby pin down the gene in the early
1980s that was a task not like looking
for a needle in a haystack but like
looking for a needle in Central Park
nonetheless after in ten years of work
she did eventually find a marker that
was consistently different and by 1993
the gene had been isolated and in recent
years it's been deciphered the sequence
of it has been read and the difference
between people who have the disease and
people who don't have the disease is now
very well known and it's a fantastically
strong predictive thing there's a phrase
in the middle of the gene called CAG
which is repeated several times in most
of us repeated about most of us it's
repeated about 10 to 20 times but in
people that where it's repeated more
than about 39 times then they get
Huntington's disease if it's repeated 39
times then on average they'll get the
disease at the age of 66 if it's
repeated 40 times they'll get it at 54
59 41 times they'll get it at 54 and so
on so in other words from knowing how
many times this one word is repeated in
the middle of this very large gene we
can tell pretty well exactly at what age
somebody is going to get Huntington's
disease now that's an immense step
forward in the sense of predictive power
of diagnosis but as is I think going to
be the case very often in
medical genetics in the next few years
diagnosis has left therapy behind there
is still nothing you can do about it
hunting's disease is incurable we're
beginning to understand why that gene is
important inside the brain what it's
doing and thereby hopefully beginning to
be able to step down the road towards
designing a drug that could prevent it
but at the moment as Nancy Wexler
herself has said were in the position of
terry's yes the blind seer of Thebes who
was punished by one of the gods by being
given the power of seeing the future but
being able to do nothing about it and
interestingly a lot of people who are at
risk of Huntington's disease fact most
people who are at risk choose not to
take the test choose not to take away
the uncertainty of knowing whether their
so-called fifty percent chance is
actually a hundred percent or nawt
percent but actually in a way that's a
bit misleading Huntington's disease is
not typical of genes and how they work
the the idea of that that simple
predictive power you either have this
disease and you have this version of the
gene or you don't is not the way it's
usually going to be and very few of us
have a risk of a serious disease like
Huntington's disease but many more of us
are likely to get Alzheimer's and in the
case of Alzheimer's we've also been able
to pin down some genes that are
associated with predicting whether or
not you will get it on chromosome 19
there is a gene called a PO II which
comes in two versions one version of it
has as its 330 fourth letter the letter
G instead of a and that difference means
that if you have two copies of the e4
version as opposed to the e3 version as
they're called and seven percent of us
do have two copies of that version then
you are 11 times more likely to get
Alzheimer's in later life however it
doesn't mean you're definitely going to
get Alzheimer's and it doesn't mean that
if you haven't got that version of the
gene that you're definitely not going to
get Alzheimer's
and under those circumstances most
bioethicists feel that it's not right
for people to start going out and
testing themselves to see whether
they've got this because they will
either be to falsely reassured or to
falsely scared by the the information
that they'll get I think that's right
but I'm beginning to wonder if we've got
to be not a little more careful that
decisions like that and they're going to
be many many more of them this is just
the first of them as to whether or not
you should be allowed to go out and test
yourself for your chances of getting
Alzheimer's decisions like that should
in the end be up to us to take and not
the experts to take on our behalf that's
certainly my gut instinct but it's it's
a very tricky issue and of course once
we do start testing ourselves for
Alzheimer's disease and you find you've
got a high risk of it the first thing
you might do is go and take out some
appropriate insurance and then of course
if we all start taking out insurance but
only the things we're at risk of the
insurance industry will go under and
we'll all be worse off so the insurance
industry will start demanding to see
what tests we've taken on what results
we've had and then we have to guard our
genetic privacy against that these are
difficult and troubling issues but as I
said genes are not there to cause
diseases and by concentrating only on
the things that go wrong when the gene
goes wrong we perhaps misunderstand the
nature of jeans a bit a good example is
a gene on chromosome 7 which is known as
the Cystic Fibrosis gene really the
first and most famous gene to be found
but it's of course very lives leading to
think of it as the gene for fistic
fibrosis it it only causes cystic
fibrosis in one version when it goes
wrong and it turns out that the reason
that one version is in is in the
population is because it's very
protective against typhoid if you've got
one copy of it you are pretty well
immune to typhoid if you've got two then
you suffer from cystic fibrosis so you
might as well call it the typhoid
protection gene if you like but then of
course that's just as misleading because
the gene in its
normal version is doing something else
altogether but as I said genes are not
there to cause diseases they're there to
do things like build our body put up by
a chemistry together put our bet brains
together and thereby of course produce
our behavior and I think many much of
the interest in the genome and genes
inside us is in the extent to which they
determine or they implicate or they
affect our behavior dean hamer has been
has looked into a gene called d 4dr on
chromosome 11 which is a which contains
a 48 letter phrase you're getting used
to this idea I think now repeated
phrases in the genome and how they how
they come to mean things and this 48
letter phrase is repeated between 2 and
11 times in in each of us and it turns
out if you have a long version of this
gene with lots of repeats then when you
take a personality test questionnaire
you have a slightly different
personality from people who have a short
version of this gene you're more novelty
seeking people with a short version of
the genome or cautious dean hamer gives
one example of what he means by novelty
seeking and cautious behavior he says
that heterosexual men with the long
version of the gene turn out to be six
times more likely to have slept with a
man than heterosexual men were the short
version of the gene but homosexual men
with the long version of the gene turn
out to be four five times more likely to
have slept with a woman than homosexual
men with the short version in other
words for both those cases novelty
seeking behavior seems to have been
encouraged by the longer version of the
gene now this is beginning to sound a
bit scary the idea that the shape of a
particular gene can determine what we
are who we are and and how our
personality develops but nobody least of
all dean hamer is claiming that this is
the key to all personality let alone not
even all or not even to explain all
novelty seeking of a cautious behavior
he says you know it's a tiny tiny
influence on us but it does show up a
consistent difference and the reason you
chose to look at that gene is because
it's a dopamine receptor gene
and dopamine is one of the brain
chemicals involved in the kind of
behavior that you that is expressed in
novelty seeking or cautious behavior but
it's just the first glimpse I think of
many many genes that were going to find
that do have an impact on personality
and they're due to some extent define
who we are in a software sense as well
as a hardware sense but if you think
that genes determining your behavior is
rather a scary thought there is I think
some some some help at hand and it comes
from well a good example is another of
these genes that we that we share with
flies another thing we can learn about
the roundish flatworm is that it could
it could remember things are you mating
that's a rather remarkable statement to
make about a creature whose shape we
don't even know and lived 600 million
years ago but again there is a very
similar set of genes in fruit flies and
in people which are involved in the
system of memory in the brain if you
want to amuse yourself one day you could
put a fruit fly in a test tube and put a
little metal grating in the test tube
and and then pass an electric shock
through the metal grating and you'll
find that the fruit fly doesn't like it
and it flies off the metal grating as
soon as it feels the shock you may think
this is a rather unpleasant thing to do
but it was done at the University of
California in the 60s to to as part of
an experiment to discover whether fruit
flies could learn and it turns out they
could because if you puff a little
chemical into the test tube just before
you do the experiment then the and you
do this consistently the fruit fly will
gradually realize that as soon as it
smells the chemical it's about to get an
electric shock and it flies off the
grating not you might think a hugely
sophisticated thing to do but it was
actually the first evidence that animals
like flies could could learn at all
there was no evidence before that they
could and by doing this a group of
geneticists were then able to find fruit
flies that however often they puffed the
smoke in
didn't learn and always got the electric
shock and it turned out that these were
genetic learning mutants that were
missing one of the genes that enabled
them to learn the first was known as
dunce and that's now the name of the
gene the second was called cabbage the
third was called amnesiac the third was
called rutabaga than radish then turnip
and finally the last one has been is
called vlado which I'm told is Chilean
slang for an absent-minded professor you
can be flippant when you're dealing with
genes in fruit flies I don't think it
would be approved of in Mysore people
the point about these genes is that they
they control a system called a crab
system inside a part of brain cells and
when they're switched on they cause
connections to strengthen or weaken
between brain cells which is literally
the process of laying down the memory
but the point is that they're switched
on by the outside event the genes are
only switched on to create the memory
when the memories is caused by the
stimulus from outside so it's sort of
the opposite from the personality gene
that I was talking about before where
your behavior is caused by the gene here
the behavior causes the gene to switch
on and this is one of the reassuring
ways I think in which one big one can
begin to realize that the relationship
between genes and behavior while
undoubtedly a very strong one is not all
cause and effect it's not always genes
that are calls and behavior that's
effect it's often the other way around
so that it's actually going to turn out
to be a very very complicated system in
which you you can't be deterministic you
can't just say that genes cause the way
we are parenthetically I just like to
add a little bit at this point about
eugenics because a lot of people i think
are beginning to get concerned and
rightly so that this power of knowledge
that we have over our own genes will
enable us to start
fiddling with jeans and insisting that
people fiddle with their own jeans so
that we as it were change the nature of
humanity the first half of the 20th
century saw some really horrible
eugenics programs not just in places
like Germany but also in this country in
Sweden though not curiously in Britain
my own country which invented the
concept of eugenics but never applied it
there were never any eugenic laws which
allowed the compulsory sterilization of
people as the work in other countries
based on their IQ a lot of people say
that eugenics is a terrifying example of
what will happen if we let science go on
being untrammeled but actually if you
look at the history of eugenics it was
invented before Mendel's genes were
rediscovered and it was invented largely
by people who resisted Mendelian
genetics who were so-called biometry
shins they believed in a different form
of heredity from genetics so in a way it
was a it was based at its birth on
ignorance rather than knowledge it was
also based on statistics the four most
famous founders of of eugenics were all
very famous statisticians which leads to
rather comforting conclusion that we
should ban statistics and the other
thing that people forget about eugenics
is that it was enthusiastically
encouraged by socialists in its early
days it was the Fabian's in particular
who are urging the use of eugenics
because it was a form of the
nationalization of reproduction it was a
form of planning now scientists were
also a lot of them particularly in
Germany very enthusiastic eugenicists so
they should definitely not be left of
the hook but my point is simply to
broaden the net and to show how it was a
crazy piece of sheep like behavior by
the whole of society by elements from
all across the political spectrum and
all across different professions that
went hurrying down this this route
towards nationalization of reproduction
towards coercion of people's rights and
the important lesson we have to learn
from the eugenics movement of the first
half of this of the
century is that the decision as to who
to who can reproduce who can do anything
with genes must belong to individuals
and not to the state that must never be
coercion about these things if it seems
to me I'd like to end by talking a
little bit about determinism and free
will because again I think people find
it rather alarming the idea that we are
the products of our genes that there are
these implacable little puppet masters
sitting there pulling strings and making
we making us how we are I've already
given you one reason based on those
learning genes as to why that shouldn't
be the way we look at it because quite
often genes are at the mercy of our
behavior rather than the other way
around but there are several other
reasons I think for thinking just a
little differently about determinism
than the way we do the first is that
actually people quite light determinism
now what do I mean by that well we all
read horoscopes or a lot of us do and if
you know if you read a horoscope you are
buying into the idea that in some sense
your future is determined but another
perhaps more realistic example is that
when the gay gene was postulated in the
early 1990s as a result of work by dean
hamer incidentally that particular
stretch of the x chromosome that was
thought to be associated with sexuality
has now largely turned out to be a red
herring it doesn't seem to be associated
with it nonetheless the evidence for
some heritability of homosexuality or
heterosexuality does still seem to be
quite strongly there when that happened
as I think many of you may have noticed
the reaction of the gay movement was not
to say I don't like the idea that we are
determined by our genes on the whole
they welcomed the news because they said
see it's not a choice it is actually
part of our intrinsic make up some
reacted that way some didn't but it it's
not immediately obvious that that that
being
wind by your genes is not something that
in some cases will be welcome news
rather than unwelcome news but the other
point is that the alternative to genetic
determinism is usually a form of social
determinism and essentially the the
nature-nurture debate that rave that way
was waged throughout the 20th century
was all about whether the influences
honest came from social influences from
the environment or whether they came
from within us from genes it's of course
in a sense of meaning least argument
because many genes only work in certain
environmental conditions and many
environmental conditions only work given
certain genes etc they both have to be
in place but nonetheless social or
environmental determinism is still
determinism if you say that you are the
product of your upbringing or your
background or your class or some
particular formative experience that you
had in your youth you're still just as
much determined by that there is no
escape from determinism by saying that
it was social rather than genetic in
fact it's perhaps the difference is the
genes are at least within you they are
part of you whereas social determinism
allows other influences outside of you
to determine who you are a good example
I think of this is the debate over
autism autism was thought in the 60s and
50s to be the product of an interaction
between the parent and the child and and
a lot of parents went through terrible
guilt and pain on essentially being told
that the autistic child was their fault
nowadays we reckon we recognize that
autism is much more intrinsic to the
autistic person and is not caused by a
particular background and in fact in
fact the reason that parents of autistic
children appear to be less than
sympathetic is because they
sometimes given up trying to be
sympathetic so it's caused by the autism
rather than the other way around but I
said a moment ago in reference to the
gay gene that it might be welcome news
that you are fatalistic ly determined to
be the way you are but of course you can
choose another example to tell exactly
the opposite story that just because you
are determined by your genes doesn't
mean that you there's nothing you can do
about it and a good example would be
dyslexia again rather like autism a few
years ago dyslexia was the view of
dyslexia changed from being something
that was caused as it were by inadequate
teaching of some kind to being caused by
something inside the child and we now
recognize dyslexia very much to be an
intrinsic part of the child it's not
necessarily purely genetic that may well
be effects that happened in the womb or
something that are not particularly
related to genes that cause it
nonetheless and it's it's an its its
part it's an intrinsic part of the
nature of the person but has that led to
us concluding that therefore because
dyslexia is innate therefore it is
useless to try and teach dyslexic
children that they should simply be left
out of the education system of course
not quite the reverse we've actually
come to the conclusion that we've taken
much more seriously the idea of remedial
education for dyslexic people I just
leave you with the thought on that that
if you believe in the meritocracy if you
believe that people should people should
have their own worth recognized and
should not be judged purely on their
background or their upbringing or their
educational qualifications then you are
to some extent believing in a genetic
determinism you are believing that genes
matter that's the only way you can be
that's the only thing you can be talking
about so the simple idea that genetic
determinism is a bad thing and the
environment is a much better thing is
something that I have come after writing
this book to field needs to be strongly
challenged I think it's actually a great
relief to find that in most things like
IQ and so on the harder you look at them
it's not that you find that there's more
genetic determinism environmental but
that there's a rough balance of about 50
50 of each which is I think a reassuring
conclusion well where does that leave
free will Immanuel Kant argued that we
are only free because we can reason that
our ability to to go against our
instinctive determinism 'he's was caused
by the fact that we actually reasoned
our way to what we should do I don't
find that a very persuasive explanation
of free will it it feels much more
deep-seated than that but I don't think
it's an illusion either and it seems and
I you know at this point I begin to
throw up my hands are not a philosopher
I don't understand these concepts if we
are the product of both our upbringing
and our genes then how is it that we
feel that we can be spontaneous at any
point in the in the world I think the
answer has to lie somewhere in what's
generally known nowadays has chaos
theory that determined things don't have
to be predictable it's the only way to
get off being impaled on a dilemma which
i believe is known as Humes fork after
David Hume the 18th century philosopher
because Hume said that either our
actions are determined in which case
there's nothing we can do about them or
they're random in which case there is
nothing we can do about them thank you
very much indeed
I'm very happy to answer any questions
if I can see you it's a little bright in
the middle there I reveal my ignorance
here if you let's say you found some
gene it was the bad cancer gene you
basically go in with something like
tweezers and either take out the good
part or put in the bad one and since
you've got six trillion of these copies
floating around in your body I'm the
numbers stager me yeah it's when you put
it like that it doesn't sound very
hopeful does it and that's why actually
I didn't talk about gene therapy which
is what you've talked about there is it
is possible to okay the question was if
you fight if you have a bad cancer gene
can you go in with tweezers and replace
it and but if so how come how can you do
that in six trillion cells in your body
gene therapy aims to do that by
stitching the corrected version of the
gene into a virus putting the virus into
your body so that it infects every cell
in your body and hopefully it's a virus
that's been made safe so that it doesn't
actually cause debilitating disease
while it's happening and there are
people who've been cured by gene therapy
now I think one can just about say that
the definition of cure in these cases is
still a bit undefined but there is a
particular disease called severe
combined immunodeficiency with which
children are born unable to fight
infections because of one gene that's
not working and they very easily succumb
to the slightest disease and in severe
combined immunodeficiency using a cold
virus that's been modified to carry the
correct gene to cells in the body
they've managed to use the virus to
infect enough cells so that the immune
system starts to work in the in the
child so gene therapy should not be
ruled out but it is as we've seen from
recent events a dangerous procedure and
it's far from working well and actually
it's not the only just because you find
a gene that's not working it doesn't
mean that the only thing you can do to
make it work is to replace the gene
there are plenty of examples where once
you understand what the gene does you
simply find another way of putting in
either the genes product or the chemical
that the gene is supposed to or removing
the chemicals the genius approach to
eliminate or something like that so that
there are tons of other ways of
approaching the problem once you've
understood what it is the genes doing
than gene therapy the first part of the
question is given the length or the
number of these things in in one unit in
one cell how is it possible to say there
that's blue eyes and the second part of
the question is well blue eyes is one
thing blue eyes is objectifying but
you're then you talked about risk-taking
yeah which sounds relative to blue eyes
like huh I know it's it's it's
incredible isn't it I mean yeah you know
ok the question sorry the question is
how how in the the entirety of this
enormous document can you pin down that
this bitties is to do with blue eyes and
secondly how is it that that that
something like risk-taking behavior
could actually be caused by just a piece
of digital text is that a way of
summarizing how do you object if I
risk-taking yeah ok right well in that
case it was easy you just simply give
people a questionnaire and ask them you
know lots of questions you know there
are personality questionnaires designed
to elicit personality I'm nobody's
pretending this is rocket science you
know they're nobodies yet building much
on this but you divide the group the
people into two groups the you know that
the high risk taking people in the low
risk taking people based on the answers
they give to the questionnaires you then
look at the G
so we did the other way around and be
cheating of course you then look at
their genes and you find there is a
slight consistent difference in answer
the first part of your question yes it
is it's mind-blowing Lee difficult to
imagine how you can find a particular
stretch of text in in this sort of giant
document and if you sort of think about
it hard enough you'd give up and go home
but luckily some very farsighted
biologists have worked out ways of doing
it and essentially what what DNA does
that other forms of text don't is that
it binds to a copy of itself there's a
sort of mirror image of itself that it
that it will stick to so if you put a
little stretch of the particular text
that you're trying to find into the test
tube you can extract the bit that is or
isn't like that it's a bit like using
the facility in microsoft word that says
search for this stretch of text and it
does it almost as quickly I mean I could
get into how the test tube's works but
you'd quite quickly realize that I don't
know what I'm talking about in this
field I'm not a molecular biologist sir
yeah age to what you would you care to
comment on the place of genes in cloning
the question was can genes age and would
I comment on the the role of genes in
cloning and jeans can't age that's one
of the wonderful things about digital
text is that it's how many times you
copy it as long as you copy it
faithfully you you know the message
never decays now as I said chromosomes
can age because their ends can fray and
you start losing bits of jeans off the
ends and that seems to be a key part of
the aging that happens in our bodies but
the genes themselves don't age and the
genes in our germ cells which are kept
sort of secluded from the rest of the
during our lifetimes and are much better
repaired better looked after as it were
so that you don't get any infidelities
in the copying you know the text is
maintained to a higher standard they're
immortal if you think about it I mean
you're descended from the germ cells of
your father who was descended from the
germ cells of his father and so back to
the roundish flatworm and Beyond and in
that sense you know there is immortality
and you can immortalize human cells it's
been done with cancer cells which are
used in laboratories just you know as
human cell tissue to test medicines on
they they are remotely just sort of go
on dividing forever so aging is
something that actually has to be
switched on inside the body by certain
genes ie switching off the telomerase
and then other things that happen aging
is planned obsolescence in us and that's
why you can throw it into reverse I now
can't remember the second question
cloning thank you yeah well cloning is
is really just bypassing reproduction
sexual reproduction and taking a cutting
from a human body like you take a
cutting from a rose bush and growing it
up into a complete so in a sense
therefore it doesn't have very much to
do with jeans I mean it obviously uses
jeans like every form of reproduction
does but it the the understanding of
what's in the genome doesn't either make
cleaning easier or harder or depend on
cloning now it's true that the one of
the reasons they are cloning animals
like Dolly the sheep and and the cows
and so on is so that they can have an
easier mechanism for feeding particular
genes into into creature so that you can
boost milk production in a cow or
something like that but in a sense I see
the cloning issue is almost separate
from the genomic issue
okay these jeans does that make you then
susceptible to diseases where you may
have been immune to it at one time and
I'll repeat the question which is the as
you age the chromosome phrase at the
ends and you lose jeans off the end of
it does that make you more susceptible
to diseases I don't think so now I don't
think that's the way it works I mean the
reason you become susceptor you do come
become more susceptible as you grow
older to infectious well I suppose you
do eventually but that's because whole
body systems start to fail the immune
system starts to weaken and so on and
essentially there's a sort of well to
put this aging is about as I said about
the certain systems getting sort of
switched off other systems getting
switched on and so on but there are
definitely genes that control it there's
no question we now know because we've
done it in fruit flies and it's even
being done in mice that you could alter
aging so that people did live much
longer and the question is whether it
would be desirable or legal so why do
you feel that this would not lead to the
vision of all this Huxley
and alpha people and beta people why
wouldn't a government or even and ensure
a Mont you know just a powerful
insurance company like entity create a
world in which people were divided by
their genetic makeup identical heard the
question but why wouldn't it lead to a
brave new world like Aldous Huxley
described in which people were divided
by their genetic makeup or by a
government or an insurance company
forcing that honors the first point on
that is a very interesting one which is
I went back in read brave new world the
other day when I was writing this book
and I discovered there's almost nothing
about inheritance and genetics in it the
difference between alphas and Epsilon's
in the book is all conditioning and Bree
and and of Lothian conditioning it's all
behavior ism it's all environmental
changes you know they the babies are
born and taken off into these special
rooms and sort of groomed for their
roles in life so actually it's an attack
on 20th century environmental
determinism you know psychiatry and
behavior is Amanda more than it's an
attack on eugenics or genetics which is
an interesting point that nobody picks
up on but go and read the book and
you'll see what I mean but nonetheless
you know too I think you were using that
fairly loosely and what you meant was
why couldn't we do the same using
genetics why wouldn't we do the same and
I hope we've learnt the lesson of the
20th century that the interests of
society should never be put before the
interests of the individual well as they
never but you know that it's very very
dangerous to fall into that way of
thinking because that after all is is
one of the big lessons of the 20th
century it seems to me and for that
reason you know it might be you people
often think that evolution should be
about the good of the race the future
the you know the whole species and that
that individual interests should be
sacrificed but if you look at the
history of in vitro fertilization it's
exactly the opposite
infertility is if you like a form of you
know sin against natural selection which
would normally have been cleansed from
the species by by natural selection
that's a sort of eugenic way of putting
it but instead we've gone down the route
of saying just because you're infertile
doesn't mean you shouldn't have the
chance to breed if we can find a way
around it so we've individualized that
piece of medicine we've said the
individual is more important than the
species or the race or the society and
it seems to me if we keep that principle
firmly in mind whenever we come up
against the insurance industry whenever
we come up against employment problems
then sure this is going to create huge
problems for the insurance industry but
it won't create problems for you and me
except to the extent that eventually
rebounds on us so the important point is
that the individual owns his own genome
it doesn't belong to the state to the
experts to the doctor to the insurance
company to the employer to anybody else
that seems to me the only principle that
we've got to remember it's not easy and
I'm not saying that's the only answer
but it's it's the sort of guiding light
I better go further back okay yeah just
saying that there seems to be a worry
about insurance companies or the
government and we got to be the owners
of our own DNA and we are supposed to
make a choice of whether we want to
disclose it or not I think that what
that sounds very rational there is also
actually an inherent danger in just that
that those with the let's say better
genes disclose it voluntarily and
therefore actually you know get
favorable favorite treatment so you
could make an argument the other way
around and saying you know this should
be kept it's not your property but it's
something that should be just kept
secret from everybody or it should be be
now known by it from it by a by
everybody in order to avoid that people
almost do divinian like yeah
move you know just close when they have
a favor set of genes I think that's
that's a very interesting point and
there are a number of ways we could go
one is to say that the div you if you if
you find that you are sorry they well I
think my own the question will become
apparent from my answer I have either we
could we could go down the route of
saying that people can indeed have their
genes tested and reveal the information
to their insurance company in the hope
of getting a lower premium because
they've actually at lower risk of
various diseases just as they
voluntarily disclose nowadays that they
don't drink or they haven't got a
history of heart disease in the family
and if they do that as you say most
people OTT of people will be better off
but the result is that insurance will
have to become more expensive for those
who don't disclose the information and
then you you're eventually left with a
sort of uninsurable group of people who
are a very high risk or who are refusing
to take the test or refusing to reveal
the results of the test and you then
have to find a way of dealing with that
perhaps through government programs or
something that's one way to go and the
other way to go is as you say to say not
only is it your property but you have a
duty not to disclose it to anyone that
genetic confidentiality is a two-way
street not just that they can't demand
it demand the knowledge of you but you
mustn't reveal it so that the whole
system of insurance remains intact and
remains based on pooled risk and so on
I'm no I'm not an expert on the
insurance industry and how it works I
think I think these are you know we've
got to decide which of these ways is
most equitable and which is the right
way to go I think it's a fascinating
debate that should be joined I'm going
to try and find someone right at the
back so make some rough estimate of the
time line for the development of drugs
that are attributable to this new
information yes I mean how long is it
before we're going to see drugs based on
genomics and Jen
well I think we're already seeing some
and the the the pharmaceutical industry
is looking very very hard at this data
as it's coming out and is working very
hard to design genes drugs based on
genetic information just one example as
a gene called p53 on chromosome 17 which
turns out to be a very very important
cancer gene it's a tumor suppressing
gene it actually gets rid of incipient
tuned tumors and it's only when it
breaks that a tumor turns malignant and
they're already the whole the system
that p53 sets in motion is being studied
very hard and there are already
candidate drugs in phase 1 2 3 trials
which are based on trying to do what p53
should be doing if it was working
properly in the tumor and so on so there
are drugs in the pipeline already based
on genomic knowledge but if you think
that that's based on four or five
thousand well known genes at the moment
and that by June we'll have eighty
thousand or so human genes that are well
known it gives you some idea of how much
increased possibility there is to find
cures for diseases in what's coming I
don't think it's going to jump up that
quickly because pharmaceutical research
is such a slow business particularly cuz
of safety testing and efficacy testing
it does take years to develop drugs it's
not like the internet which is going to
suddenly come along and transform our
economy in a few years it's a gradual
take off from here into the next decades
right over there
it was
Express and well because Alzheimer's is
is it is it did everybody hear the
question why would a the Apple for gene
on chromosome 19 if it made it if it was
11 times more likely to give you
Alzheimer's why would you definitely not
get Alzheimer's have you had it because
it turns out that Alzheimer's is a
complicated disease affected by a whole
number of genes and all we're looking at
here is one of these that increases the
susceptibility so that if if your
chances of getting Alzheimer's was say
2% without that gene its twenty two
percent with it that's an 11-fold
increase but it still leaves you with a
pretty good chance of avoiding
Alzheimer's if you had I don't know
whether that's the right figure for the
population at large but it could be
something as low as that and most
diseases like Alzheimer's are going to
be caused by a mixture of environmental
effects genetic effects and a genes that
interact with each other there's another
gene associated with Alzheimer's which
very definitely causes Alzheimer's if
you've got this this version of that
gene you really do have a very high
chance of getting it but it's a terribly
terribly rare gene ie most of us have
the normal version of that so although
that would be a you know predictive
thing to go out and test people for
whether they've got that it's so rare
that it's sort of not really worth
worrying about and that's so you know
the picture is going to be very
complicated in those sort of ways in the
middle
you can genetics that you can reverse
the aging process yes I think it's very
likely that once we understand genes we
can reverse the aging process there are
lots of genes involved in aging it's
much more complicated even than the
Alzheimer situation I suspect so we've
got to get them all because otherwise
you end up with a sort of dorian gray
like situation where you've reversed
some of the aging you know you you might
look like you're 35 but inside your head
yer 75 or whatever but the the evidence
from fruit flies is that you really can
reverse the aging process by selective
breeding which implies that there is a
lot of genetic influence in there and
one or two sort of visionary scientists
are talking about immortality as a goal
for a couple of centuries hence I didn't
believe a word of it right in studying
genes you hear about companies patenting
different information I understand what
you haven't met when you develop a
medicine you can patent it but when they
get this information on jeans what's
patentable and what isn't it's like
they're patting your body away from you
what can you patent and what can you
it's a very good question and as you
know there are two rival human genome
projects at the moment one of which is
private and is relying on patents for
its income and the other which is public
and which is dumping its data into the
internet as it produces it the answer is
that nobody really expects to patent a
particular stretch of text in the DNA
and just say look I found this bit it
says agggghhhhh CTA that's mine please
can you pay me royalties every time you
quote it like a copyright nobody's going
to get away with that what they can do
and what Craig Venters company seller is
doing is charging a big pharmaceutical
company five million dollars to look at
it to search his database just to sort
of use the information he's found and
see what you can find
and they're also trying to say well we
found this stretch we think it's
associate with an Alzheimer's disease
gene we think that they're that by
producing an antisense version of this
text which is a sort of blocking version
of the text we might be able to design
an anti Alzheimer's drug so let's write
all that down call it a patent
application and try and get a patent on
it again you know it's a pretty long
shot that because it might turn out that
method wouldn't work etc etc and it
wouldn't really block other ways of
using the same information essentially
there are various levels of which you
can try to patent and nobody's nobody
denies that if you do five years and
five million dollars worth of research
on developing a drug you should be
allowed a 17-year pattern to protect
your position and earn back the money
you've spent and that's the way the
pharmaceutical industry works but the
knowledge per se is not not really
patentable and I think and one of the
main reasons it's not patentable is
because this public project is going to
produce the same knowledge and dump it
onto the internet and once it's dumped
and freely available anyone can use it
thank you waving waving furiously
tonight but which studies with you
recommend to a young person in order to
be able to work in your feet um good
question we've been talking a lot about
aging what studies would I recommend to
a young person to be able to work in in
in your field I mean my field is not
genetics I write about it and I I'm you
know one thing I should stress is that
I'm not a practitioner of any of this
stuff I'm just very interested in it's
now been following what's going on in
the literature and I strongly recommend
anyone amateur or not who's interested
in in science and philosophy to to to
watch what's going on in genetics it's a
fascinating time to be alive I think
but it to me I think perhaps the answer
to your question what kinds of research
should someone go into who wanted to to
make an impact and who to hit in really
interesting area and I think almost
anything to do with the brain and
genetics is going to be a very fruitful
area I talked about personality i talked
about learning as we as we uncover this
document layout this book we're going to
find eighty thousand genes we know
already from one estimate that probably
half of those are expressed only in the
brain they only have some purpose in the
brain so I think that and the great
mystery is how the brain works is still
you know in many ways unknown it still
is still a bit of a black box to us and
it's a tremendous the most complicated
machine on the planet and it would be
very nice to begin to get an
understanding of what's going on inside
it and how it works and I suspect
genetics it's going to be a good way of
getting into that it's not the only way
and it can't do it all itself there are
other brain science approaches that are
equally important but they I think we'll
use genetics as part of it well thank
you very much indeed ladies never